as the protests surrounding presidents
Trump immigration refugee executive
order grew over the weekend uber came
under fire for the great crime of having
turned off their surge pricing to JFK
Airport in New York in order to help
travelers get home what was so terrible
about that the New York taxi workers
Association had participated you know
one hour work stoppage to join the
protest against Trump's executive order
so uber was supposedly undermining that
protest even though uber turned off
their surge pricing to avoid making a
profit only initiated that policy half
an hour after the stoppage ended and
ubers executives actually opposed the
Trump executive order but that was not
good enough virtue signaling has swept
the nation with leftists policing each
other to determine who doesn't clap the
longest so we can shoot them and now
BuzzFeed has joined the fray just weeks
after their idiotic targeting of HGTV
couple chip and Joanna Gaines for
destruction because they committed the
grave sin of attending a church where
the Bible quote the pastor quotes the
Bible on homosexuality BuzzFeed now
wants to target every other company it
can find and give it the uber treatment
BuzzFeed San Francisco bureau chief Matt
Honan tweeted quote we're following
which companies are speaking out on
Muslim ban and which are not
buzz feeds Tom Guerra then ran a piece
in which he suggested as Silicon Valley
debated its leaders stance on
immigration ban corporate America simply
said nothing at all Silicon Valley
Guerra wrote said quote something which
is more than can be said for the rest of
Corporate America whose leaders have
largely remained behind a wall of
silence since Friday's announcement even
as plenty of their employees and
customers at home and around the world
were facing the prospect of being banned
from entering the United States so
here's the question is it truly
necessary for every company in the
United States to take a position on a
controversial executive order that is
actually not a Muslim ban that has not
yet been fully interpreted and that is
still being adjudicated in the courts
did every company in America have the
responsibility to sound off on Obamacare
in fact when corporations did sound off
on Obamacare if you recall the left
called them whiners and told them to
shut up the left wields the media as a
club in its fight to push the country to
the left and simply staying out of the
fight that's no longer tolerated if you
do business you're expected to do the
bidding of the left which means the
right will have to respond in kind in
order to compensate for the leftist
bullying and every company will be
forced into the polarizing political
space rather than merely providing the
best go
services at the most competitive prices
on behalf of their shareholders that
isn't good for consumers it isn't good
for companies it isn't good for the
country if people want to speak out by
all means they should if they don't want
to speak out that's their prerogative to
and if they don't want to turn their
companies into political footballs over
issues that aren't even close to
clear-cut that is certainly justifiable
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show all righty I got to tell you folks
I mean under Trump it just feels like
every event in the next ten years has
been crammed into one year it's amazing
it's amazing you know my wife always
says that when you're not having fun
time moves incredibly slowly that's also
true when events move this quickly and
right now what we're watching is an
administration that has been for years
long it's been a week and a half I mean
it's truly amazing there's so much going
on and we'll get to all of it but first
we have to say thank you to our
advertisers over at texture comm so if
you love magazines if you're an
information addict the way that I am
texture comm is for you actually there's
a guest that I'm trying to get on the
show I read about in a Reader's Digest
article not because we subscribe to
Reader's Digest but because my wife uses
texture texture allows you to browse all
of these magazines check their back
issues subscribe to a huge number of
magazines for $9.99 a month and it
includes tons of major publications
we're talking people Better Homes and
Gardens Reader's Digest National
Geographic Sports Illustrated Vanity
Fair Rolling Stone and Cosmo and just
it's the list is about a hundred
newspaper magazines long and you get
access to all of them there's a the
story that I'm talking about actually
there's a lady amazing lady who takes in
children who are terminally ill she
takes in babies who are terminally ill
and have sort of been abandoned and she
adopts them until they pass away which
is an amazing story I read that in
Reader's Digest again not the Reader's
Digest but through texture calm and it's
it's the best reading aggregation
material you can find texture calm you
can download the app and again right now
it's normally $9.99 a month and you get
200 magazines actually 200 magazines but
if you sign up right now at texture comm
slash Ben you get a 14-day free trial so
you can try it out see if it's something
you like I promise you you will it's
really fantastic it's entirely digital
and so that means you're not gonna have
to get all the magazines to your house
obviously texture calm slash Ben try it
for free
14 days when you use that code slash pen
that also lets them know that we sent
you great service text recom my wife
loves it I love it and it actually is
helping to find the show which is pretty
cool okay
so it was a busy weekend a couple of
notes that we have to make before
anything else everybody on both sides is
constantly attempting to attribute
genius to their side and the other side
there's this broad widespread public
perception that people in politics
generally know what they're doing they
generally know what they're talking
about that there must be a big plan so
if Trump appears to have screwed
something up no must be part of a
conspiratorial shadowy plan no maybe you
just screwed it up and if the left screw
something up then there's on the right
this tendency to attribute it to some
evil shadowy conspiracy maybe it's just
that they're incompetent as Adam Carolla
is fond of saying you know one of the
one of the most disappointing facts
about life is when you're a child do you
think the adults know what they're doing
and then you become an adult you realize
that adults are idiots they're just
stupid you know that you thought when
you were a kid that they all have cars
and houses and that means they're smart
you thought when you're a kid the
President of the United States knows
what he's doing the media know what
they're doing know everybody's stupid if
you start from that premise politics
becomes a lot simpler clearer and more
truthful so we begin today with Trump's
of course Immigration and Refugee
executive order the media have lost
their freakin minds over this thing
they've lost their minds over it so
we're actually going to go through it
and we're going to tell you what's in
the executive order is it a Muslim ban
no is it legal maybe is it useful kinda
was it rolled out like a bunch of like a
bunch of monkeys having to head trying
to have intercourse with a basketball
yeah I was basically rolled out at that
as badly as you could so here's what was
actually in the executive order we'll
start with what's in it then we'll talk
about whether it's useful and legal and
then we'll get to the left insane
response because it is totally over the
top it is totally crazy and that's only
the beginning of the stuff that was
happening over whoo it's pretty Wow it's
gonna be a busy for years gay okay so
number one the executive order invokes
911 so Trump says because of 9/11
because it's refugee because of attacks
by people who have come into the United
States on student visas we really have
to crack down on the visa system and
that means that we're going to crack
down on the on the visa system we're
going to
down on both immigrants and
non-immigrants meaning people who visit
the country as well as people who are
attempting to immigrate to the country
and we're gonna crack down on all of
that the order suspends visas from
Nationals of countries of particular
origin so the Secretary of Homeland
Security as well as Secretary of State
and the DNI Director of National
Intelligence are tasked under the order
with determining the standard necessary
for visa entry within 30 days they're
gonna rewrite the standard all entering
in the United States is suspended as
immigrants and non-immigrants of such
persons for 90 days from the date of
such order so these are the countries
this is where everybody's saying you're
not able to get in if you're from Iraq
Iran Syria Libya and in a couple of
other countries not Afghanistan not
Saudi Arabia not Pakistan that's one of
the flaws in this and we'll get to that
in a second the order also states there
may be more countries that are added to
this banned list so again it's seven
countries they're talking about is
Tehran Iraq Syria Libya Somalia Sudan
Yemen those are the seven that they are
talking about the Secretary of State and
homeland security are able to waive the
executive order for individuals so if
they determine that there's an
interpreter who wants to get in from
Iraq they can waive the executive order
okay
refugees are blocked for 120 days all
refugees are blocked for 120 days while
we come up with new standards Syrian
refugees are banned indefinitely until
Trump says okay so they're given a
special standard priority is given to
victims of religious based persecution
so what it says is that the Secretary of
State is directed to make changes to
prioritize refugee claims made by
individuals on the basis of religious
based persecution provided the religion
of the individual is minority religion
in the individuals country of
nationality so the idea here presumably
is that Christians living in Syria will
be given higher priority they'll still
be able to get in Muslims who are
refugees from Syria are gonna have a
harder time now that isn't actually a
major shift from current refugee law
current refugee law defines a refugee as
any person who is outside the country of
such persons nationality and who is
unable to return to the country because
of persecution or a well-founded fear of
persecution on account of religion so
that obviously encompasses Christians
the fact is that the Obama
administration really cracked down on
Christian immigration from Syria which
was truly an awful awful thing they took
in I think single-digit numbers of
Syrian refugees who were Christian in
the last year but they took in tens of
thousands of Syrian refugees were not
that's that's ridiculous the order
limits the number of refugees total in
2017 to 50,000 people is all wow that's
just awful okay except that was the
normal standard like three years ago it
was only up to in the last couple of
years and then you get into the screw-up
so all of this is basically okay it's
actually relatively moderate this isn't
a giant Muslim ban they're 1.5 billion
Muslims all around the world they're not
going to immediately be banned from the
United States the most populous Muslim
countries are still allowed to send
people to the United States they're not
banned again this doesn't cover a lot of
the countries it probably shouldn't
cover like Pakistan and Saudi Arabia and
Egypt rate doesn't cover a lot of those
places all it is it's it's temporary
moratorium it's on outright ban so it's
not a Muslim ban okay there's no way
this is a Muslim ban I've read the text
members of the media should bother
reading the text but they don't it's not
a Muslim ban folks
it just isn't and the media is lying
about that which brings us to the roll
out so the way that you normally would
roll this thing out let's say that you
did this in a normal fashion first you
run it by the office of legal counsel to
make sure that the thing is well written
legally second you probably want to pair
it with some sort of executive order
regarding how to help refugees right so
you don't look like you're inhumane so
what you would do is you'd say we're
signing an executive order to help fund
the creation of safe zones in Syria and
in the Muslim Middle East for Syrian
refugees that they're not just getting
slaughtered in Aleppo instead they have
a place to go but they're not gonna come
here right that's the idea that's what
you know and invite whether it's
actually Trump's policy he wants those
safe zones
he could have announced that at the same
time he didn't third you make sure all
the agencies are on the same page you
say we're gonna implement this you tell
all the agencies we're gonna sign this
thing right and you give them draft you
say we're gonna sign this thing and when
we sign it it's gonna go into effect but
you have all have advance warning you
know how this is gonna work
instead the way this was rolled out is
Trump signed it nobody in any of the
agencies knew what was going on
DHS didn't know it was going on the
Border Patrol didn't know what was going
on and so they called the White House
and they said okay well you know this
this order doesn't make clear what
happens to people who already have visas
right how about people who already have
green cards what do we do with those
people and DHS said what we'd like to do
is let them in and then if you want to
check their visas later check their
visas later but don't hold them up at
the airport or turn them around just
because there
visiting family back in Iraq or
something instead they went to Steve
Bannon and Steven Miller now I need to
be clear about something with Bannon and
Miller Bannon is the superior Miller is
the inferior ok Bannon is the one in
charge Steven Miller is a 33 year old
speechwriter who has some policy
expertise on immigration
Steve Bannon is the chief strategist to
the White House Steve Bannon is like 60
years old and has Trump's ear and is
very very tight with Bannon the person
who is the subordinate here is Miller
Miller's the one being tossed under the
bus that is not fair here's what CNN
reported the White House overruled the
guidance from DHS according to officials
familiar with the roll out that aura
came from the president's inner circle
led by Miller and Bannon okay it should
really read Bannon and Miller Bannon is
the powerful one their decision held
that on a case-by-case basis DHS could
allow green heart card holders to enter
the United States before the President
issued the order the White House did not
seek the legal guidance of the Office of
Legal Counsel apparently they didn't
bother to go through the standard agency
review process at all and it is worth
noting that Donald Trump over the
weekend also changed the constituency of
the National Security Council to add
Steve Annan who really is not qualified
to sit on that thing and get rid of the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
which just makes no sense at all if you
want Bandhan in there at least don't get
rid of the Joint Chiefs I mean my
goodness or the DNI they got rid of Mike
Pompeo as well so this is this is
incompetent so two things can be true at
once one the executive order isn't
nearly what the media are preferring it
to be it is not a Muslim ban it's
actually rather moderate and two this
could be just a botched abortion of a
rollout and it really was it's just an
awful awful rollout of a really not that
big a deal program but everybody is
making it into the end of the world
because now you've got all these
pictures of all of these people kids old
people trying to get into the country
and they have visas and they've been
here for five years on a green card and
now they're stuck at the airport and
then you have the the reunion pictures
with all the people cheering around like
like Trump is trying to ban Muslims from
the country and the hashtag Muslim ban
trending even though it is not it is not
a Muslim ban so let's go through a
couple of quick questions about this
thing first actually before we get to
going through a couple of quick
questions first we have to say thank you
to our other advertiser for today and
that is D STL decom so if you love jeans
and I do I wear jeans pretty much every
day you would know that if you could see
my pants but you can't but I wear G
pretty much everyday and and the jeans
that I wear are from DST LD comet is
luxury great denim and it goes for about
75 bucks so jeans don't normally cost
you a couple hundred bucks I mean I have
a pair of jeans that cost 200 bucks my
DST LD jeans are just as good they're
they're durable they were really well
they fit really well and it's not
bargain bin stuff I mean it's
high-quality jeans 75 bucks DST LD come
they also have jackets so they have
bomber jackets and they have a bunch of
new stuff that's really good-looking and
great they guarantee the fit they'll
send you a new pair if you don't like
how it fits and they eliminate those
excessive markups because they don't use
middlemen they just mail it directly to
you go to DST LD comm slash Bend right
now and get $10 off your first order
DST LD distilled DST LD comm slash pen
right now 10 bucks off the first order
so 65 bucks for a pair of jeans DST LT
comm slash been distilled calm and they
do really make high quality product so
we want to answer a couple of questions
and then we'll get to the left's
reaction so answering a few questions
about this first of all is this
unprecedented no it's not totally
unprecedented the media is making this
out to be the end of the world no one's
ever done anything like this before no
there are a couple of precedents that
are worth noting one President Obama had
a six-month ban on Iraqi refugees in
2011 second in 1980 Jimmy Carter issued
a ban on Iranian visa holders so there
are a couple of differences between what
Trump is doing now and what Obama and
and Carter did
first off Obama's order only affected
refugees so Trump's order actually
affects green card holders now they're
backing off of that by the way but it
presumably only affected green card
holders it affected Green article there
was a student visa as travel visas
affected everyone whereas Obama's was
only refugees and and Obama also
implemented the policy quietly Trump did
so openly so people say it's bad press
okay I don't really care
Carter about Carter spouse he put a
moratorium on new Iranian visas with an
exception for humanitarian purposes so
he didn't ban refugees and a
cancellation of then-current iranian
american visas the purpose of that
policy was to get the Iranians to give
up the American hostages it wasn't meant
as a broad-based indefinite policy so
it's sort of like those cases and it's
sort of not like those cases I wanted
as honest as possible in how we analyze
the actual law how about the legality of
this thing is it legal or is it not
legal and this is what people are asking
because courts have issued stays on
parts of this executive order there's a
really interesting kind of legal
argument for people who like the
specifics between Andy McCarthy of
National Review on one side and David
buyer of the Cato Institute on the other
it really comes down to two provisions
of immigration law one provision says no
person shall receive any preference or
priority or be discriminated against in
the issuance of an immigrant visa
because of the person's race sex
nationality place of birth or place of
residence so that would seem to prevent
these sort of bans on certain areas of
the world that it's discrimination on
the base of place of birth or place of
residence okay that's provision one
provision two says the president has the
capacity to suspend the entry of all
aliens or any class of aliens as
immigrants or non immigrants on the
basis of saying that they are
detrimental to the interests of the
United States the question is which one
of these legal provisions is the more
powerful is the one that gives Obama
that gives the president gives Trump
lots and lots of power or is the one
that limits that power so buyer argues
that it's the it's the
non-discrimination provision that's more
powerful and McCarthy argues that it's
the presidential provision that's more
powerful not really clear that's the
part that's gonna be adjudicated in the
courts there's pretty good case on both
sides okay finally is this actually a
smart order is the executive order
actually smart so there are a couple of
problems with the order itself first of
all does it achieve its stated purposes
so the media is pointing out that
foreign-born refugees are responsible
for like two deaths in America in the
last ten years or 15 years and so
they're saying it's not it's not
calibrate it's not well calibrated to
achieve its purposes and people on the
right are saying well you know it's it's
common sense you got to do it now this
sort of mirrors on the one side to be
intellectually honest this sort of
mirrors on the one side the arguments
that have been had over birth control
p.m. not birth control gun control
rather the the the idea that they'll put
a blanket ban on assault weapons and
people like me will say yeah but it's
all weapons don't kill that many people
they aren't using that many shootings
and let's say right but it's common
sense we have to do something okay now
you have to calibrate the solution to
the actual problem I agree that if we
can't vet refugees regardless of whether
they're terrorists
we didn't let people in we can't vent
that's just a good general principle
just as there's a background check a
federal background check that happens
when you get a gun this is for mental
illness and for criminal background
check the same thing is true when it
comes to if you're a federally licensed
firearms dealer that's true the same
thing should be true when it comes to
coming into the country immigrating into
the country so it's not really about
Syrian refugees per se it should be
applied to everyone it should be we're
creating a new standard for visas and
applies to everyone and the reason for
that is that it's actually under broad
right it's too narrow what if somebody
comes from Saudi Arabia let's say on a
student visa or travel visa they
overstay their visa this policy doesn't
really apply to them per se it doesn't
stop them from coming into the country
they're from Saudi Arabia right not from
one of these seven named countries well
every hijacker on 9/11 was from Saudi
Arabia or Egypt they have a Pakistan
lots of terrorists come from Pakistan
doesn't do anything about Pakistan right
so if you're gonna cite 9/11 is your
rationale you should actually calibrate
a policy that would have stopped 9/11
otherwise you fall into the same trap as
folks on the left when they say that
their policy wouldn't a stop Sandy Hook
but it's good anyway right he actually
needs a tailor the policy so that it'll
help stop things so this is why I say
this is a pretty narrow policy it
actually is not a broad policy it's a
pretty narrow policy second of all it's
an over broad application again stopping
people in the air with no warning is
just foolish it leads to bad press the
whole thing was done idiotic Lee and you
can tell how idiotic Lee it was done
because Van Daan's already tossing
Miller under the bus bannon's already
saying Steven Miller's fault like Joe
Scarborough today was ripping on Steven
Miller it's been ins its bandhans fault
right I mean the fact is that Bandhan
abandon is the guy who's who's largely
in charge of these executive orders but
he's blaming Miller to get out of it so
that's that's where we stand on this
thing now
the left has lost its mind for that for
us talking about what the left has
responded you're gonna have to actually
subscribe it's a Lee Weyer calm and you
can watch the rest of the show there it
can also be part of the mailbag you can
watch the show live we have new books
and pamphlets coming out we have new
shapiro gear that's coming out all which
is very exciting at the shapiro store
daily wire.com 8 bucks a month gets you
a subscription
eight dollars in annual subscription
will get you a signed copy of my novel
true allegiance which was fantastic and
there are more goodies to come we're
going to have a new giveaway I think
pretty soon as well so that's exciting
daily wire.com to become a subscriber we
are the largest conservative podcast in
the United States
[Music]
you